Eigentlich ist das hier
ein großes Announcement-Video.
Und ich bin auch sehr aufgeregt.
So aufgeregt wie vielleicht noch nie.
Aber eins nach dem anderen.
Freunde der Sonne, wir müssen reden.
Erst mal, was ist eigentlich
mit maiLab los?
maiLab, jeden zweiten Donnerstag
um 06:30 Uhr.
(Grillenzirpen)
Das ist offensichtlich eine Lüge.
- Lügenpresse!
Erst mal Danke an alle, die uns
liebe Kommentare geschrieben haben,
dass sie unsre Videos vermissen,
ob's uns gut geht.
Uns geht's gut, nur das,
was grade auf dem Kanal passiert,
ist alles, was ich derzeit schaffe.
Bei maiLab ist der Arbeitsaufwand
pro Videominute ...
insane, ja?
Also, die Produktion
ist das kleinere Problem,
die redaktionelle Arbeit ist krass.
Wir lieben es.
Wir könnten natürlich
den Arbeitsaufwand reduzieren
und dafür mehr Content machen,
aber das will ich nicht.
Im Gegenteil, die gewachsene
Reichweite motiviert mich dazu,
noch mehr Arbeit reinzustecken.
Denn: With great Reichweite
comes great responsibility.
maiLab geht weiter!
Erst mal weiter unregelmäßig,
aber immer in höchster
inhaltlicher Qualität.
Denn so verstehen wir eure Abos.
Dafür habt ihr abonniert:
für guten Inhalt.
Also, wenn ihr's
nicht verpassen wollt,
könnt ihr die Glocke drücken.
Denn wenn wir kommen, dann richtig.
Aber natürlich machen wir nicht
nur monatelang ein maiLab-Video.
Ein sehr schöner Grund
für die seltenen Uploads
sind meine zwei
neuen Fernsehprojekte.
Eins davon habt ihr mitgekommen,
wenn ihr mir
auf Insta oder Twitter folgt.
(off:) "Terra X", Wunderwelt Chemie
mit Mai Thi Nguyen-Kim.
(Mai:) Momentan läuft
meine erste große "Terra X"-Doku.
Eine dreiteilige Doku
zu meinem Lieblingsthema: Chemie.
Yes!
Diesen Sonntag kommt Teil Drei
um 19:30 im ZDF.
Es gibt auch alle drei Teile
in der Mediathek.
Aber besonders aufgeregt ...
bin ich wegen dem,
was auch am Sonntag
um 22:15 auf ZDFneo kommt:
Meine erste eigene Wissenschaftsshow!
(Applaus)
"Der TikTok-Algorithmus
weiß offenbar besser ..."
Da ist es! Da ist die Werbung.
(off:) Wissenschaft mit Leidenschaft.
"Ist jetzt endlich nur
trockene Statistik."
"Immer diese Scheißwissenschaft."
(off:) "MaiThink X - Die Show".
(Jubel)
Jetzt kommt das eigentlich Wichtige:
Die allererste Sendung, die Premiere
von "MaiThink X - Die Show",
werdet ihr vorab hier sehen können.
"Erst mal Hallo Freunde der Sonne."
- (viele:) "Hi."
Stellt euch die Wecker:
Sonntag, 18:00 Uhr, hier bei maiLab,
noch bevor es abends
im Fernsehen läuft.
Ich mach jetzt
seit ein paar Jahren Fernsehen,
aber eine eigene Show from scratch
zu entwickeln und zu starten ...
ist noch mal was anderes.
Euer Lieblingskeksteam
hat jetzt also zwei Herzensprojekte:
"maiLab" mit dem SWR und funk
und "MaiThink X" mit dem ZDF.
Neben Melanie, Lars und Jens
hab ich nur noch ein paar weitere
Menschen für die Show hinzugeholt.
Produziert wird das Ganze
von der wundervollen
"bildundtonfabrik", "btf", in Köln.
Natürlich kann man mit so einem Team,
mit lauter genialen Leuten,
noch mal ganz andere Dinge machen
als das, was ich hier zu Hause mache.
Es ist so unreal, dass diese Sendung
jetzt wirklich im Fernsehen kommt.
Weil die allererste Idee
für diese Show
hatte ich damals
am Anfang der Doktorarbeit.
Lange, bevor ich selbst
YouTube gemacht habe.
Damals aus einer Zuschauerperspektive
heraus, wo ich mich gefragt habe:
Warum gibt's keine coolen
Wissenschaftssendungen
für Menschen wie mich?
Für Nerds,
die es genau wissen wollen,
die komplexe Inhalte haben wollen,
die nicht runtergedumpt werden,
aber gleichzeitig weltnah sind,
aktuell, politisch relevant.
Das Thema der Sendung
kann ich noch nicht verraten.
Ich kann nur so viel sagen:
Es ist soooo wichtig.
Ich würd mich wirklich freuen,
wenn es möglichst viele sehen.
Es ist wirklich wichtig.
Natürlich werden
auch grade neue Sendungen
oft an der Quote gemessen.
Zum Glück zählen da
Onlineabrufe auch mit rein.
Ihr könnt euch vorstellen,
Fernsehpublikum ist etwas träge.
Also, neue Sendungen
haben's nicht immer leicht.
Deswegen, für Support jeder Art
und Weise, weitersagen, teilen,
wären das ganze Team und ich
sehr dankbar.
Weil da einfach
verdammt viel Herzblut und Arbeit
reingeflossen sind.
Es muss sich ja gelohnt haben,
dass dafür maiLab ausgefallen ist.
Den Rest der Staffel könnt ihr immer
sonntags um 22:15 auf ZDFneo sehen,
natürlich auch in der Mediathek.
Gerne auch "maithinkx" folgen
bei Instagram und Twitter.
Da gibt's auch
zwischen den Staffeln Content.
Ja, ich bin superaufgeregt.
Es ist ein Riesenschritt für uns.
Ich hoffe, ihr geht ihn mit.
Danke für den Support,
fürs Zuschauen.
Und wir sehen uns bald.
Bis dahin: Bleibt sicher.
(Dynamische Musik)
(off:) "MaiThink X - Die Show",
ab dem 24.10. auf ZDFneo, mit mir ...
(off:) Mai Thi Nguyen-Kim.
Mai Thi N- ... guyen, also, kann ich
nicht so gut aussprechen, Kim.
(zögerlich:) Mai Thi Nguyen-Kim.
(Mai korrigiert:)
Mai Thai Nguyän-Kim.
(Dynamische Musik)